hello and welcome to swype coming up
holiday hyperbole our online reviews
spoiling the spirit of adventure
internet matters we take a look at the
new organization designed to help
parents monitor what kids see online
robo catch the four-fingered robot that
has lightning speed reactions and
next-gen goat stimulation in this week's
games review book anything online these
days and you'll usually find a wealth of
user feedback close by from star ratings
to comment boxes even forum discussions
but according to a new study we're less
inclined to trust the rave reviews we
read so given that many of us are
booking our holidays online at the
moment Katie Spencer slapped on some
factor 50 to work out if what we read
should be shaping where we go for many
travelers when we plan our holidays
user-generated online reviews have
become the go-to source for information
how far can we trust a 5-star rating the
British hospitality Association says
it's in talks with tripadvisor one of
the world's largest travel sites over
claims holiday makers are holding their
members to ransom demanding upgrades in
exchange for not writing bad reviews so
can we really believe everything we read
we are seeing increasing numbers of
malicious reviews being posted either by
members of public or maybe by
competitors of the hotel or restaurant
concerned and that can be incredibly
damaging now of course if you're not
providing an up to scratch service then
you deserve the bad reviews that you get
people rely on these websites so much
that you know they see these reviews it
can actually have a very direct impact
on a company's business however a new
study in the journal of consumer
research has found that negative reviews
aren't always bad for business it's
research showed we're more likely to
trust people's experiences if we believe
it's written in an honest way and take a
leap of faith when it comes to booking
it also found we've become more switched
on when it comes to looking at reviews
and spotting fakes something which can
be seen in tripadvisor's figures with
more than 150 million reviews on its
site savvy holidaymakers apparently
spend forty five percent more time
looking at hotels which have more than
50 reviews over half of us wouldn't make
a booking if we don't see any reviews so
sorting the fact from fiction is a
priority in recent years it's introduced
sophisticated tracking systems to look
at the electronic attributes of each
review as well as taking on fraud
experts to investigate anything which is
flagged up the benefit of a site like
ours is that you get the wisdom of the
crowd it's a little bit like the
principal in polling pollsters know that
the more people that they ask a question
to the bigger the sample size the more
accurate results and it the same is true
of online reviews the more reviews you
read the more accurate picture you build
up there's no doubt travel reviews have
become an essential reference tool but
are they killing our spirit of adventure
what it certainly does is remove the
spontaneity and as a traveler what I
like is to be the Explorer have the
discovery in the adventure things that
get my attention is more the negative
interesting things that you wouldn't see
on on the hotel's website sometimes
you'll see a bad review and and then the
restaurant will put a comment saying oh
we're fixing this right now okay so I
thought that was interesting because I
think it keeps people who are countable
of course nobody wants to be caught out
when booking that perfect getaway when
it comes to writing online reviews
sharing the experience can be half the
fun Katie Spencer Sky News you're
watching swype coming up twitter hits
the mute button but first how about
living in a world where you never have
to hunt around for a phone charger or
one in which you can print out your own
robot helper while the technology is on
its way Intel hosted its innovation of
future showcase this week so we asked
Matt Steele to check it out it's an
insight into the technology of tomorrow
for just a few days in London Intel set
up a temporary home to introduce people
to some of the advances its end
Shania's believe could be heading our
way soon built in 3d cameras could help
our computers to see in the same way we
do and when our devices can view things
in greater depths it could lead to big
improvements especially when it comes to
things like gaming and gesture control
if our computers can see objects in 3d
that information could then easily be
stored passed on to a friend and print
it out somewhere else using a 3d printer
you are giving you a computer for new
fundamental ways to understand inputs
when you're using applications your
hands for things like gesture your face
so I can understand your emotions speech
so that you can speak to it like you
speak to another human and the
environment around it so that it can
gain contextual awareness get fed up
hunting for a charger well this isn't a
fruit bowl it's a smart bowl you just
pop your devices inside to charge
everything wirelessly you can just place
your devices directly into the charging
bowl and they start charging so with
that we provided user is kind of a very
elegant seamless way to charge their
devices without having to manage
multiple cables then there's Jimmy the
robot first revealed at the Maker Faire
in New York last year is the idea that
eventually we could all print our own
robots the open source files have
already been shared with a number of you
nice to enable them to create and print
their own Jimmy's on a 3d printer people
are invited to invent and share ways to
improve him then different apps could be
downloaded to improve what he can do
envision this robot becoming part of you
part of your life just like technology
has you know like your cell phone like
you can configure your cell phone today
imagine having a robot that you can do
that with you know 3d printing has
really evolved to be cost-effective and
definitely more accurate to realize
those dreams Intel insists some of the
prototypes could be here as early as the
end of this year it might be slightly
longer before Jimmy makes his way into
most of our homes but as processors
become smaller and more powerful the
possibilities are becoming seemingly
endless Matt Steele Sky News you're
watching swype coming up the
four-fingered robot that could beat you
in a game of catch
but first if you're a parent's working
out what your child's looking at online
can be a bit of a worry but a new
not-for-profit organization which
launched this week in the UK is hoping
to set the bar when it comes to internet
safety Tom Platt has the story with a
whole generation of children on the web
in a way their parents never experienced
or necessarily understand a new
initiative is helping to protect kids
online internet matters launched by the
UK's four major broadband providers is
helping parents safely navigate the
internet with their children sky BTW
virgin media and TalkTalk are teaming up
to protect kids online with big names
backing the campaign one of the things
that was so exciting about it when i
first discovered using the internet is
that the boundaries were so broad and
you could look up so many things in it's
all in one place but obviously for my
kids I want to make sure that it's all
age-appropriate and they're not going to
be confused right to set by what they're
seeing the project is meant to be a hub
for information directing parents to
help and advice from specialist
organizations and charities it's also
designed to put pressure on the tech
industry to make a child-friendly
internet more effective with parents and
policymakers working together the
internet is an absolutely fantastic
place for our children they can be
hugely creative it can be educational
but as it becomes more and more
commonplace in their lives that can be
exposed to things that we don't want
them to see I can appropriate content
and that's why it's important that we
help our parents keep their children
safe online with a report showing that
fifty-five percent of parents are not
monitoring their child's internet usage
and over half not using parental
controls the initiative will come as
welcome news to safety campaigners but
may take more time to change old habits
tom platt Sky News you're watching swype
coming up we check out the next-gen goat
simulation and no it's not a joke but
first here's anything you might have
missed over the past few days and
there's some tweets you'd rather avoid
without having to block the tweeter well
it's now possible twitter has turned on
a mute feature allowing you to turn off
certain tweets so they won't show up in
a timeline the new tool appears to be
what the social media giant was aiming
for when it changed its blocking policy
December igniting a firestorm of
controversy and while we're on the
subject of birds don nguyen the greater
of flappy bird the game which snowballed
into a massive hit earlier this year has
an out still be bringing it back in
august despite tweeting in February that
he couldn't take the attention anymore
he's told a news channel in America he's
making a modified version xbox one
owners have been getting het up this
week after Microsoft announced plans to
strip out the consoles Connect feature
and slash prices sales of the device
have been flagging in comparison to the
ps4 but some fans are concerned it means
Microsoft will have less incentive to
make use of the motion sensor which they
forked out extra for england goalie joe
hart better watch out check out the
lightning speed reactions of this
four-fingered robot researchers at the
swiss federal institute of technology
reckon it's one of the fastest in the
world and could eventually be used to
collect space debris the inventor of the
bagless vacuum cleaner and the bladeless
fan was written to do more to attain its
engineering talent James Dyson has
announced plans to invest a quarter of a
million pounds and expanding his company
it will [ __ ] he'll create three thousand
new jobs but also wants the UK to do
more to encourage overseas students who
are learning in the UK to stay where
they're studying nearly ninety percent
of our researchers at British
universities in engineering and science
come from overseas and we ought to make
them more welcome indeed nearly half the
undergraduate studying science and
engineering are also from outside the EU
so I think if we made them welcome from
the very beginning and said that you
know when you qualify you can stay in
Britain and help Britain create
interesting products that we can export
rather than dis encouraging them they go
home and then they become competitors to
us I mean this is sheer madness Google's
announced an update to its map service
the company says it will enable a more
intelligent guide for those using public
transport with access to the time and
root of every train bus tram and ferry
in the UK and finally it turns out the
author of Game of Thrones has been
writing the fantasy drama on a computer
that will be more at home in the seventh
kingdoms in a TV interview in the states
george RR martin the man behind the
books on which the TV series is based
confessed his secret weapon was an old
dos computer is to prevent viral attacks
and also so he doesn't have to worry
about autocorrect constantly changing
one he writes no confirmation though if
he does it all set up his own mini Iron
Throne although I would mario kart 8 may
bring anti-gravity to the world of
racing but will it save the Wii U games
Ross Thompson reviews the highly
anticipated Nintendo offering along with
some other new and upcoming releases
first up there's Wolfenstein so you
could prolly say that this is the
creator of first-person shooters this
franchise but you've got Wolfenstein the
new order which is coming out on
playstation 4 xbox one ps3 xbox 360 and
PC and this takes you to a world where
the Nazis of One World War two and
you're in the 1960s and it's your aim to
basically cone take back Europe and take
back the world from the Germans who
literally have overrun everything and
changed the way that they may have
changed the world if I had won World War
two there's a great storyline to this
it's a looks amazing so graphically
fantastic so yet great first-person
shooter and looks amazing obviously on
current-gen and next generation and PC
so highly recommended
next up is goat simulator now goat
simulator was originally released as a
pc download title only and it basically
took people by storm it was only really
made by a very small studio no one
really expected anything from it but
they're suddenly this whole phenomenon
happened around social media and YouTube
and everybody got behind it so someone's
now signed up the rights to basically
release it as a boxed version with a
disk so this is coming out as well and
the game itself is just crazy you are a
goat you are running around and the idea
of the games just to destroy absolutely
everything but try and destroy it in
style so you can imagine trying to jump
out the window as a goat doing a
backflip but hitting a frying pan at the
same time and then landing on a barbecue
which then sets the house on fire on the
garden on fire and the more points you
get the better you are and then you can
literally people are uploading all these
different videos so it's going to be a
huge success again you then have mario
kart 8 which is coming to wii u nintendo
really need this but we use not had the
best of years over the last since its
launch a mario kart 8 is that major
franchise that's really going to deliver
for that console it's got all your
favorites back in there from previous
Murray carts but there's also some new
special editions they've added into this
so one of the key things is they've got
anti-gravity cards now so that means not
only are you going to just be racing as
normal on a standard road but you're
also going to be racing the walls on
ceilings and it just completely changes
the perspective of this game it looks
stunning in HD it's the first time Mario
karts being in HD and all in all 12
player online multiplayer as well this
has got success written all over and
it's really what a Nintendo need to
start making the wii u a real want for
people again america is definitely that
games do so
watch dogs is an IP that was announced
about two years ago at e3 and people
have been talking about ever since so
now finally they're gonna be able to get
their hands on it it's in a near future
Chicago and it's all about technology
you play a gentleman called Aiden Pearce
who was a thug in his previous life but
he turned into a hacker and it's all
around being able to utilize technology
to control absolutely everything in
Chicago and go after these guys that
basically ruins your life even though
you're a thug in the first place you can
control traffic lights which means if
you're in a car chase you can be being
chased by 2030 cars but change all the
traffic lights to cause a massive pileup
they will then crash after you can get
away you can turn lights off and
basically just take down the whole black
out the city you can stop trains you
control CCTV cameras so it's a really
ingenious idea and it looks like it's
going to be the start of a massive
franchise so all in all watch dogs is
definitely one to watch out for thanks
Ross and that's it for this week
remember you can catch up with the
breaking tech stories all week on sky
use for ipad smartphone app and sky news
com I'll see you next time bye bye